Now, before we get into the hands-on sections of the Animation Production Workflows course,
let's talk about the Sequencer features and tools for animation.
Beginning with the workflow features.
So one of the features that users will run into when working with Sequencer is the Allow
Edits options.
There are three options found in the Allow Edits pulldown menu, and the first is to Allow
All Edits, which allows you to make all edits to any asset in a level sequence, level, or
sublevel.
The second option is to Allow Sequencer Edits Only.
This option prevents any edits you make to the assets in the persistent or sublevels
by only allowing changes to the active level sequence assets that are contained inside
the Sequencer Event Manager.
The last option works in much the same way as the second.
The Allow Level Edits Only option limits users to making changes only to the assets that
belong to the active level or sublevel but are not necessarily part of the level sequence.
Another feature you will find in Sequencer is the Motion Blending option, which is essentially
bone matching.
And that allows users to match a specific rig bone from one animation track to a previous
or following animation track by right-clicking on the animation track and choosing which
clip and bone to match with.
The next Sequencer feature is Animation Track Blending, and this works in conjunction with
Motion Blending.
Animation Track Blending includes several preset easing options, much like the easing
options that are available when blending camera cuts tracks, and as we build out the animation
assembly in the hands-on section, we will combine Animation Track Blending with Motion
Blending to create a complete animated sequence.
Now, working with Sequencer, users will encounter two types of Transform Tracks.
The first type is the Standard Transform Track that functions on any static mesh actor added
to Sequencer.
Standard Transform Tracks have four options available to the user.
Absolute, Additive, Relative, and Additive from Base.
Absolute overrides and ignores any existing keyframe animation and zeros everything out
at the origin or initial state.
This allows an animator to create new animations that replace any existing animations.
Additive is the next and most common Transform option that layers new or corrective animations
on top of the existing animations applied to an actor.
After that is the Relative option, which serves as a blend between Absolute and Additive options.
As the name suggests, this option creates animations that are relative to the position,
origin, and existing animations.
Personally, I don't use this option all that much, but it does have its purposes.
And lastly, the Additive from Base works just like the Additive, but uses the Base animation
as its origin point.
The next type of Transform Tracks are Control Rig Transforms.
With Control Rig, there are only two Transform options, Absolute and Additive.
These function the exact same way as the Standard Transform Tracks.
Absolute overrides and ignores the existing keyframes, creating a new track for every
control on the Control Rig.
While Additive is the second option, and just like the Standard Transform, Additive is also
the most commonly used Transform as it allows for the modification, layering, and correction
of any existing animations on every control in the Control Rig.
OK, so I want to take a moment and remind you of Sequencer's function as an Event Manager.
And as we work through building our animation assembly and applying the inverse solve for
Control Rig animation, the Event Manager is where all of your tracks and controls will
be located.
As you animate with Control Rig or add Transform Tracks and keyframes to your animation, you
will also be working with Sequencer's Curves Editor, activated from the Sequencer menu.
Additionally, I also want to note that the Curves Editor and Event Manager are not limited
to just Control Rig animations, but both work with Take Recorder, Cinematic Event Triggers
for Assets, Blueprints, Niagara, Composure, and Material Parameter Collections.
Alright, that's it for the workflow features of this section.
In our next Sequencer Features and Tools section, we will discuss working with the Animation
Mode Tool Set.